so before this before we started the
podcast we were talking in the living
room and you and also agreed on
something so with you this is what I
noticed when it comes to work you cry
when you're not working but when you
finally do get work you cry even more
yeah you just you're never happy with
what you have like explained to me that
process and why that happens okay um I
cry right when I don't have work because
I want to work okay and I cry when I
have work because it's usually work I
don't necessarily wanted to do but
that's what's given to me but then when
you're doing the work you want to do I
still cry you're ever gonna do yeah I'm
never happy
so when are you winning when do you feel
like you're winning i I just this
discovered this recently I'm winning
when I'm looking back in hindsight mmm
like I'm I can be happy for myself three
years ago but at the time it was all
anxiety of whether either it's gonna
disappear or it was so slow that I you
know should I get a job or I was so busy
that I was having a nervous breakdown
cuz I never got time off like it was
never I never was like oh I feel like
really cool right now yeah but in
hindsight I can be happy for myself
that's true that's true I do that a lot
like I remember I miss that when when I
remember when I was doing doing that
thing I missed I was complaining the
whole time resting on the ground I hate
telling people to [ __ ] alright like in
disbelief that people think so much of
you well a perfect example is let's say
he was offered an audition offered to
read for a part
mm-hmm he'll then come home cry and be
like what the [ __ ] why do I even have to
audition still so then the the Dale Dale
day okay don't audition
well they offer him the part and then
now he's pissed because he's like why
don't even know it I should have
auditioned so I could go to Bart better
so he flip-flops so much that I never
know when he's actually happy so I
always never never what make I'm gonna
say this right now
all right shucks I love you guys okay
you shut the [ __ ] up I love you guys
I want to say this why I love you that I
was talking yeah yeah shut the [ __ ] up
for real yeah but I love you but uh you
know I I I have to honestly say doing
love is though is I am not even kidding
you is the closest I've become I've come
to actually let loving what I am in Wow
why like what do you think is about it
because because it's the first time
where they asked me to come in and talk
about Who I am as a person and they
wrote the role around me not only that
right but it's also like you know it's
Judd Apatow right it's you know these
people that Paul Ross the people that I
like
good write write great writers and my
friend Dave King is a writer there and
he he's it's like I show up and I go I
can I say it this way cool and they go
yeah say it that way however feels
natural whereas you could do almost
things that like notes ain't exactly the
way [ __ ] wrote it right and it's like
I'll do it that way
but it's not fun right so it's like and
also I'm around
Gillian who's all my scenes are with
Gillian and she's so cool
she really is she's like the nicest
person I've ever worked she seems really
she's like so cool and she's fun and she
makes me laugh and she's like yeah like
no issues no Holly what you see she's
easy right so I think this is the only
thing I mean MADtv was fun but nobody
that was a [ __ ] show I mean I in
retrospect it wasn't right but at the
time at the time right people were
saying that MADtv is SNL's [ __ ] right
MADtv was so much funnier I understand
that people say that but when you left
MADtv like when I did and you left SNL
you could see the difference between the
love from casting yeah it's like you
leave SNL we'll get you your movies you
know my deals this and that
you leave MADtv you're waiting in line
at auditions right and you're going on
the road and you got nothing going on so
you could really see it you know I mean
I mean and now thanks thank God for
Keegan you know me and Jordan for key
and Peele and Ike Barinholtz a success
and will and Alex Borstein all these
guys
you mean after MADtv have paved you know
I mean really good careers right and
they're credible yummy entity is now and
it's like they did that I think they
changed the perception you know me but
at the time we were we were like [ __ ]
you know mom this was full circle at
least it's not even because I think for
me the the unhappiness is like deep
inside of me I don't think it's anything
that's like I don't think the outside
world can affect it I think I'm just
always gonna be unhappy about what's
going on right now but do you think for
you is it possible that literally like
this is just the first time you've ever
really liked your role I think I think
so because he's a tough read man just
this past week alone he's actually
gotten a lot of offers and he I've never
heard him cry more in my life more in
our relationship like last night I mean
he'll say things like I love you okay I
love you okay but I'm gonna say what you
said last night okay okay he'll say
things like this he's like okay wait
other really shut the [ __ ] know shut up
shut up for a second okay I love you oh
shut the [ __ ] up on there Alex
season two all right all right if you
bring up Harrison Ford I will know I do
it if you bring up Harrison Ford I'm
gonna snap I'll take my chance and I'm
gonna I'm gonna have to I have a
position that I'm gonna say right I want
to hear both sides thank you so so
yesterday last night he's like I don't
even know why I have to memorize these
lines yeah word-for-word he's like I
don't understand why not what forward
because that's what I said because he
had difficulty with one sentence and he
was getting
frustrated so I was like well that's
what the writers wrote so that's what
you have to read right and he was like
well you know Harrison Ford and Marlon
Brando would tell writers to be like I'm
not saying that I'm except sweetie
you're not Harrison Ford or Marlon
Brando before they were them though but
he thinks he can no what I'm saying is
is this right that for a fact
oh yeah I know that it's it's it's like
Harrison Ford doesn't want to say
certain things so he just makes it more
clear the way he wants to say and he
says that stuff I think that's a known
fact right and he's always been like
that yeah okay doesn't that just depend
on the director like some directors well
that's why that's why you don't see
Harrison Ford in an Aaron Sorkin movie
because Aaron Sorkin's writing is you
have to see everything word-for-word
right who's Aaron Sorkin he did that
with the West Wing social network okay
very fast
all right guys like David Fincher right
he does a million tanks right and I mean
from what I heard Jake Gyllenhaal right
after he did zodiac didn't want to work
with him after that because he was a
nightmare right because he had to do a
thousand you are right is is that if
you're is it's Jake Gyllenhaal is right
right I'm not saying I'm as talented as
them I suck let's just throw that out
there I'm a bad actor and I don't even
deserve to work okay let's just put that
out there okay no one just listen to me
right now okay what I'm saying I'm not
saying that either okay what a [ __ ] I'm
saying I'm sorry for yelling [ __ ] I'm
saying is this is is that if Jake
Gyllenhaal doesn't want to do a David
Fincher movie he has every right not to
do one true you right because he doesn't
want to work in that environment right
all I'm saying is that you know I mean
there's a line that I have our difficult
time saying I just feel like I you know
I want to say I can't say that so you're
saying you shouldn't have to
I tried this morning I tried it 60 times
today right because I'm not Harrison
Ford right and I'm not Jake Gyllenhaal
or any of these people so I have to show
up right and do exactly
they wrote and I wasted an hour of time
trying to get this one line out and you
know I mean I've sweated and I was
embarrassed what was the line you could
feel the crew like everyone just like
the pressure um it was like if it wasn't
for this leg length discrepancy disorder
I'd be right beside him I understand
that but that was between four other
like a line and a bar and three lines
and back and you have to say it fast
right because I'm on a computer saying
it took from a guy like looking up to
right so I just couldn't do it all right
and I love the shows great he's that one
line and I did it for the show
and I will I have to shoot on the show
I'm doing son of his horn on Fox and I'm
gonna show up Thursday and I'm gonna do
it again and I love the show I love the
people but I [ __ ] up and I don't know
how to say that line and I feel bad
about it but it's like you know I've I
just last night I just said why can't I
just say it the way I want to say and
then we've got an argument about it I
could see both sides though because like
on one hand I think yeah it's like
whatever is written like that was the
vision and you're literally just the
vessel right so if you're a writer like
would you want people to read it word
for word because you put in deal yeah
same here
definitely like I don't like being
misquoted ever I can't even imagine if I
wrote something for people to read if
they changed it I think I'd murder them
right but I can also see how it's like
if you're having such a difficult time
saying it like why can't it just be
something I mean I changed it to okay
what the thing is is that I said I was
born with one leg shorter than the other
okay right so it's a condition so I said
it that way so some as if I'm not
telling the joke or the don't story
right I'm saying it the way I know how
to say it so if you wrote something
right 99% of the time I probably say it
the way you wrote it but there'd be a
couple of lines where like I want to say
it like this cuz doesn't come natural
and you would want the best [ __ ]
performance for me that's true yeah
that's true you do want it to like be
the better you want it to roll off as
that's all I'm saying
okay and I love the show son of zorn I
love love I love what I'm doing right
now and I'm grateful for the work okay
so I don't want to talk about anymore
okay all right
[Music]